[Music]
little harder huh
does this turkey think he is mickey
mantle rifle one
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to a new episode of rt
essentials i'm mark ellis and you know
life is a lot like baseball it's filled
with victories and defeats the highest
of highs the lowest of lows boring
moments and exciting ones and a whole
lot of hot dogs at least if you're me so
maybe that's why you can tell so many
interesting stories about life through
what's going on on that little patch of
grass and the dirt and the diamond
there's some pretty great baseball
flicks that have been made throughout
the years and you may find it hard to
believe but they don't all-star kevin
costner i promise but a few of them do
and they're really good and we'll talk
about those as well because today on the
show it's the best baseball movies
batter up
moneyball any other team wins the world
series good for them
they're drinking champagne they get a
ring
but if we win
on our budget with this team
we'll change the game
and that's what i want
getting the ball rolling with this list
is the 2011 baseball drama moneyball the
film is based on the 2003 book moneyball
the art of winning an unfair game by
michael lewis about oakland a's gm billy
beans attempts to assemble a competitive
team in 2002. brad pitt stars as bean
who wakes up one day with an epiphany
that conventional wisdom in baseball is
all wrong so with a shoestring budget he
starts to reinvent his team by trying to
outsmart the richer baseball clubs he
teams up with ivy league graduate peter
brand played by jonah hill and they
begin recruiting overlooked players whom
the scouts have labeled as flawed but
still have game-winning potential one of
those players is scott hatterberg played
by chris pratt with the actor shedding
30 pounds to win the role after being
told he was and this is quote too fat
but i guess it worked out since he would
go from baseball or to star-lord to
dinosaur whisper over the next four
years steven soderbergh was once
attached to the project and planned to
make it a semi documentary including
interviews with real athletes and with
real players and coaches playing
themselves but ultimately directing
duties went to bennett miller known for
films like capote and later foxcatcher
john b's on-base percentage was 477.
damon's on base
324. and el matus was 291. add that up
and you get
tormented speak
when i pointed you again
1092 divided by three
364.
that's what we're looking for filming
took place in the summer of 2010 at the
oakland coliseum and in dodger stadium
in la which was dressed up to look like
a very different ballpark the film was
nominated for six academy awards
including best adapted screenplay best
actor for brad pitt and best supporting
actor for jonah hill and it marked the
first baseball film to be nominated for
a best picture oscar since field of
dreams in 1989. if that's not on this
list i might just leave the studio the
consensus from critics is that director
bennett miller along with brad pitt and
jonah hill take a niche subject and turn
it into a sharp funny and touching
portrait worthy of baseball war and fun
fact the baseball player mark ellis
appears in the movie
bull durham fastball
hold up
[Applause]
what are you doing huh what are you
doing standing here i give you a gift
you stand here show up like picture run
dummy
stepping up to the plate next on this
list is the 1988 classic baseball
rom-com full durham the film star's
kevin costner is an aging minor league
ball player crash davis who's brought up
from another team to help guide a young
pitcher named luke lelouch played by tim
robbins who struggles with maturity
issues but both of them become involved
with annie savoy played by susan
sarandon a poetry loving groupie who
tends to find a new guy on the team
every year the film is probably based on
the minor league baseball experiences of
the film's writer and director ron
shelton who played after college for a
couple teams between 1967 to 1971. he
went on to become known for the many
films he's made about sports like white
men can't jump in tin cup which also
starred kevin costner speaking of
costner he is a former high school
baseball player and got cast in the part
partly because of that natural
athleticism he was able to hit two home
runs while the cameras were rolling
okay
you got it you got it one more thing one
more you gotta come on
all right he's gotta throw the deuce now
okay
he's gotta waste one
stay back and wipe that silly grin off
his face
come on bring it
bring it
jesus christ what was that what the hell
was that okay babe
meanwhile tim robbins was cast as nuke
against strong objections from studio
executives who reportedly wanted anthony
michael hall in the role which would
have been different since baseball films
were not considered commercially
appealing at the time every studio
passed on the project except for orion
pictures to set an estimated nine
million dollar budget and of course it
went on to gross more than 50 million
dollars in north america alone which is
called a home run in the movie biz i'm
assuming i i don't know if they use
baseball nomenclature the film has been
ranked as the number one greatest sports
movie of all time by sports illustrated
among many other best of lists in the
world of sports and it was nominated for
an academy award for best original
screenplay but lost out to rainman the
critic's consensus is that kevin costner
is at his funniest and most charismatic
in bull durham a film that's as wise
about relationships as it is about minor
league baseball
the bad news bears all season long
you've been laughed at crapped on
now you got a chance to spit it back in
their faces and what do you do you're
out there like a bunch of dead fish not
listening bonehead plays mistakes
honey don't you want to beat those
[Music]
all right i got good news everyone
because the next film on this list is
the 1976 family comedy the bad news
bears this one was directed by michael
richie who's worked on other sports
movies like downhill racer the scout and
cool runnings it stars walter matthau as
a hard-drinking x minor league pitcher
named morris buttermaker who reluctantly
agrees to coach a little league team
known as the bears but after failing to
find success with his team of misfits
buttermaker gets help from a gifted yet
feisty pitcher named amanda whirlwitzer
played by tatum o'neill at one point
during development jody foster was cast
as amanda but dropped out to be martin
scorsese's film taxi driver so tatum
o'neill got the part and went to work
with a professional sports trainer for
several weeks before filming began so
she could throw really good pitches and
while some of the ones in the movie were
done by stunt doubles o'neil ended up
throwing a lot of her pitches on her own
take note boys tatum o'neil can throw
hey charlie you hungry you want more
burrito i wouldn't eat your burrito if
you paid me too ah go on
check it it's the best way to eat it
i'm gonna kill
this very fresh film was followed by two
sequels the bad news bears in breaking
training in 1977 and the bad news bears
go to japan in 1978 along with a 2005
remake starring billy bob thornton and
directed by richard linklater and all of
them are coming in rotten on the tomato
meter there's also a short-lived tv
series on cbs that launched in 1979 and
ran for 26 episodes with jack warden as
morris buttermaker and corey feldman as
one of the players corey
but i guess it's hard to replicate the
original sometimes as critics know all
too well like slate's charlie taylor who
said at a time when sports movies can't
just be sports movies anymore it's both
startling and soothing to take a second
look at michael richie's little league
comedy the bad news bears and the
overall consensus from critics is that
the movie is rude profane and cynical
but shot through with honest unforced
humor and held together by a deft
understated performance from walter
matthau field of dreams but baseball
doesn't mark the time
this field
this game
is a part of our past ray
reminds us
of all that once was good
and it could be again
moving on but staying in the state of
not heaven but iowa for our next film
it's 1989's field of dreams if you
listen
i will read it
written and directed by phil alden
robinson from films like sneakers and
the sum of all fears this movie is based
on the 1982 novel shoeless joe by wp
kinsella it stars kevin costner is an
iowa farmer named ray who hears
mysterious voice at his cornfield one
night saying if you build it he will
come so he reacts how any of us would in
that moment he decides to build a
baseball diamond on his land despite
everybody else in town thinking he's
crazy but sure enough the ghosts of
legendary baseball players begin to
emerge from those corn fields and play
on the baseball diamond led by ray
liotta's shoeless joe jackson funny
enough the person who provided the voice
that speaks to rey throughout the film
has remained unconfirmed but we do know
that a young matt damon and ben affleck
who were teenagers when filming took
place were extras in a scene at fenway
park in boston
ray
there was reason they chose me just as
there was a reason they chose you in
this field why
i gave an interview
what what interview what are you talking
about what about evans field one to
charge you up and send you all the way
to boston to find me
you lied to me
but you were kidnapping me at the time
you big jerk well you lied to me you
said your finger was a gun those guys
are from boston i had no idea we also
know that kevin costner was not
originally considered to play ray
because he had just starred in bull
durham which maybe you've heard of and
producers didn't think he'd be
interested in another baseball film so
the role first was offered to tom hanks
who turned it down before kevin costner
did eventually get cast the legacy for
field of dreams has grown strong through
the years with the actual field
remaining open for tourists to visit and
play on and they even hosted a regular
season major league baseball game
between the white sox and the yankees at
the film site in august of 2021 playing
on an 8 000 seat field adjacent to the
original it was pretty good tv the
certified fresh film was nominated for
three academy awards including best
picture and best adapted screenplay
which both went to driving miss daisy
and the critic's consensus is that field
of dreams is sentimental but in the best
way it's a mix of fairy tale baseball
and family togetherness and you also get
some you know ghosts in there 42. all
right
[Applause]
robinson is down
[Applause]
high up on the leg and he is down
damn it slaughter you know what you're
doing
[Music]
[Music]
get me up
[Applause]
next up on this list of the best
baseball movies is the 2013 jackie
robinson biopic 42. the film was written
and directed by brian helgeland who won
an oscar for writing la confidential and
tells the story of jackie robinson the
first black athlete to play in major
league baseball during the modern era
the late chadwick boseman stars as
robinson and harrison ford plays branch
rickey defied major league baseball's
infamous color barrier by signing
robinson but this put both men in the
line of fire with the public the press
and the rest of the league with racism
coming from all sides and 42 shows the
true courage that jackie robinson had to
restrain himself and let his amazing
talent on the field do the talking
instead
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
before ford landed the role of branch
rickey was once intended for robert
redford who was developing the project
as a producer and spike lee had once
planned to write and direct a film based
on the life of robinson as far back as
1995 with none other than denzel
washington rumored to star but that
version of the project fell apart over
creative differences and now in 2013 we
got 42. it would end up being a career
altering performance from chadwick
boseman who sadly passed away in 2020.
42 is a certified fresh hit with both
fans and critics mariette poles from
time magazine said it's not easy to play
a stoic but bozeman anchors the movie
and when he smiles 42 already such a
warm story of such cold times gets even
brighter and the overall consensus from
critics is that this film is an earnest
inspirational and respectfully told
biography of an influential american
sports icon major league
vaughn into the wind up in his first
offering
a bit outside he tried to corner and
missed
all four
all eight
[Applause]
low end vaughn has walked the bases
loaded on 12 straight pitches boy how
can these guys lay off is that close
[Applause]
it's time to crank up the wild thing
intro music because next on the list is
none other than 1989 major league the
comedy was written and directed by david
s ward who won an oscar for riding the
sting in 1973 and it's about the new
owner of the cleveland indians played by
margaret whitton who wants to move the
team to miami but needs ticket sales and
a team win total to plummet first so she
leans on the most incompetent player she
can find like an injury-prone catcher
played by tom barringer and a nearby
pitcher played by charlie sheen but her
tactic backfires and the team bonds over
their dislike for her and they start to
rally and wouldn't you know it win ball
games major league helped kick-start the
career of actors like renee russo and
wesley snipes for relative unknowns
before it was released and before he was
the all-state guy or president palmer
from 24 dennis haysbert was pedro
serrano who's thirsty for some rum
rod's been looking good out there today
don't worry he'll blow it
bond's showing some signs of fatigue out
there he seems to have lost some zip on
his fastball
slow curve here's a swing and a bouncing
ball doern has a chance to make the play
he can't get a clark digging around
second he'll make it to third easily and
the a's have runners at the corners
dorne didn't get much of a jump on that
ball bonnie let's give him credit at
least he didn't spike himself
the certified fresh film was a hit at
the box office and since has reached
cult status as a favorite among many
sports fans not to mention professional
ball players and announcers it's often
referenced during broadcast just a bit
outside thanks to the one the only the
legend mr bob user that success led to
two sequels major league two and major
league back to the miners but they
couldn't match the success of the first
and they're both rotten on the tomato
meter but the film's production company
morgan creek has kicked around the idea
of rebooting more of their classic films
from the 80s and 90s which includes
young guns ace ventura and possibly
major leagues do i want them to do it
i'll get back to you the consensus from
critics on this is that major league may
be predictable in formulaic but buoyed
by the script's light silly humor not to
mention the well-built sports action
sequences and funny performances a
league of their own just seen me play
the game and did i cry
no and you know why no
because there's no crying in baseball
there's no flying in baseball
no crying
sorry jimmy what
she's crying sir
i didn't need to do that
grabs your chastiser too vehemently
much like there's no crying while
watching this show this next movie gives
us a reminder that there's no crying in
baseball either and that's 1992's a
league of their own the film is directed
by penny marshall who was inspired to do
the project after seeing the 1987
made-for-tv documentary about the
all-american girls professional baseball
week the film tells a fictionalized
story about that league which existed
from 1943 until 1954. in the film a
publicity hungry candy maker played by
gary marshall funds an all-female
baseball league as many of the country's
young men are off fighting world war ii
gina davis and lori petty star as dottie
and kitt a pair of very competitive
sisters in the league they're on a team
with characters played by madonna rosie
o'donnell amongst others and coached by
tom hanks's jimmy duggan demi moore and
deborah winger were among those
considered for the role of dottie henson
before gina davis was eventually capped
but maybe it's a good thing that didn't
happen for them because the filming of
game scenes caused numerous injuries to
actors including anne ramsey who broke
her nose renee coleman suffered a large
visible bruise and others got skinned
legs from sliding which i've done and
it's not comfy
the coach is giving keller the stop sign
could be inside
[Music]
[Applause]
the movie did well at the box office and
with critics and so a series based on
the film launched on cbs in april of
1993 with gary marshall megan cavanaugh
tracy raynor and john lovitz return it
however only five of six episodes made
it to air but don't cry because amazon
ordered a reboot of that very series in
august of 2020. and just in case the
madonna tune this used to be my
playground gets you misty-eyed that
film's famous line there's no crying in
baseball was voted as one of the top 100
best movie quotes of all time by the
american film institute in 2005. of
course it should be the critic's
consensus for this one is that it's
sentimental in light but still
thoroughly charming and buoyed by solid
performances from a wonderful cast
the natural
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
naturally we had to put this next one on
the list of the best baseball movies
because it's 1984's the natural directed
by barry levinson and based on bernard
malamud's 1952 novel the same name the
film tells the story of a very naturally
gifted athlete named roy hobbs played by
robert redford a middle-aged nobody who
comes out of nowhere to become a
baseball playing legend the movie takes
place in 1939 16 years after hobbs was
shot on his way to a tryout with the
chicago cubs now he's finally back in
pro ball as a rookie for the last place
new york knights and despite butting
heads with manager pop fisher played
wonderfully by wilford brimley hobbs
becomes one of the best players in the
league and the team starts winning ball
games
[Music]
glenn close robert duvall and kim
basinger also star alongside brimley and
redford and what was redford's first
acting role in three years following
brubacher and ordinary people in 1980.
and pun intended it seemed to be a
natural fit for redford who is a high
school classmate of los angeles dodgers
great and baseball hall of famer don
drysdale the film was nominated for four
academy awards including best supporting
actress for glenn close and critics
loved and have continued to love it jean
siskel said in the chicago tribune that
being a baseball fan involves repeatedly
experiencing exquisite pain and
exquisite joy well there's a lot of both
in the natural and the overall consensus
from critics is that though heavy with
sentiment the natural is an irresistible
classic and a sincere testament to
america's national pastime the sandlot
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and finally if you've seen this last
movie on your list you're never chasing
a baseball beyond the fence particularly
one that houses a large dog it's 1993's
the sandlot the film was co-written
directed and narrated by david mickey
evans who had written such films as
radio flyer and journeyed to the center
of the earth before this it takes place
in the summer of 62 when scotty smalls
moves to a new neighborhood and is taken
under the wing of a young baseball
prodigy and his rowdy friends who play
baseball at a local dirt with a little
bit of sand
they go on many a heartwarming adventure
together including running into some
trouble when smalls borrows a valuable
baseball from his stepdad which promptly
gets hit over a fence with big danger
lurking on the other side in the form of
a beast the film grows 34 million
dollars worldwide upon its initial
release and has since become a cult
classic and fan favorite film from the
1990s a direct-to-dvd sequel was
released in 2005 with david mickey evans
returning to right direct and narrate
and james earl jones is the only
returning cast member
oh crap i almost forgot
wait
what is it big chief
the best she smalls that's i suppose you
don't even know who the babe is either
it's blood what chewing tobacco man what
are you doing
you're killing me smalls
and another direct-to-dvd sequel the
sandlot heading home was released in
2007 and starred luke perry with
chauncey lapardi reprising his role as
squints from the original both of which
performed poorly with fans and critics
but before you say you're killing me
smalls it was reported in 2019 that a
television series with the original cast
was in the works for disney plus and i
think that's a good thing the critic's
consensus for this classic is that it
may be shamelessly derivative and overly
nostalgic but the sandlot is
nevertheless a genuinely sweet and funny
coming-of-age adventure and remember
heroes get remembered legends never die
well there you have it nine innings and
then some of baseball movie fun that's
about all the heat that i can serve up
from my version of a pitcher's mound so
i'll step aside and let y'all take a
swing at some of these fastballs thanks
for checking out rt essentials i'm mark
ellis and if i can get back to little
league one more time
hey no better no better no better no
better swing better
[Music]
[Music]
you